[Musica]
che cosa ci succede quando siamo davanti
ad un'opera d'arte
per esempio quando ammiriamo questa
bellissima scultura oppure questo quadro
meraviglioso o ancora quando per esempio
leggiamo una poesia o ascoltiamo della
musica io scommetto che qui nessuno di
noi
rimarrebbe impassibile davanti ad
un'opera d'arte perché il mistero
dell'opera d'arte e che risveglia la
nostra percezione visiva la nostra
percezione acustica ma soprattutto muove
profondamente delle emozioni e talvolta
lo fa così tanto profondamente da
provocare un vero e proprio smarrimento
un trasporto verso l'opera d'arte
ecco tutto questo mi interessa
moltissimo quando ero giovane disegnavo
molto bene tanto che avevo pensato che
mi sarei iscritta al liceo artistico e
dopo all'università adams e già mi
vedevo inserita nel mondo dell'arte è
ovvio che le cose sono andate molto
diversamente
ho fatto un percorso diverso e oggi sono
anche neuroscienziata però proprio i
comportamenti complessi che riguardano
l'arte spesso sono oggetto della mia
ricerca
il primo la prima cosa che vorrei
discutere con voi oggi è come per
esempio due campi apparentemente così
lontani come le scienze e l'arte in
realtà si intersecano guardate per
esempio queste immagini
queste immagini non sono dei bellissimi
quadri astratti sono in realtà
popolazioni neuronali che sono
evidenziate con diverse in premiazioni
colorimetriche questo non è nient'altro
che un esempio del tutto spontaneo e
involontario ma bellissimo di incrocio
tra una fine metodologia scientifica e
la bellezza dell'arte
in realtà questo dialogo tra scienza e
archi inizia moltissimi anni fa culmina
letteralmente nell'ottocento in una
città come vienna come è stato
egregiamente descritto nel suo libro
libro di cannes del non a caso premio
nobel
medicina per avere scoperto le basi
neurobiologiche della memoria
e allora vienna ogni giorno artisti e
scienziati si confrontavano
continuamente per cui per esempio i
quadri di klimt letteralmente
pullulavano di immagini biologiche ma
poi questo rapporto tra scienza ed arte
se è andato progressivamente infittendo
raggiungendo anche delle vette delle
vere e proprie vette metodologiche che
abbiamo qui questo signore se mirza chi
se mi rechi uno dei più autorevoli neuro
scienziati che ha studiato le basi
neurobiologiche delle vie visive ma come
l'ha fatto nei suoi esperimenti
scientifici ha utilizzato per esempio i
quadri di mondrian e sa che cosa sono
serviti questi quadri questi quadri sono
serviti per esempio a dimostrare l'alta
segregazione funzionale delle
popolazioni neuronali che sono
responsabili della visione o ancora
considerate queste bellissime immagini
per noi questi sono i nigmi percettivi
li usiamo continuamente per studiare il
comportamento dell'essere umano
ma cosa sono gli enigmi percettivi se
non altro che la combinazione tra luce
luminosità colori e forme ma questi non
sono i parametri che vengono
quotidianamente usati dagli artisti ma
se consideriamo una vera e propria opera
d'arte
la più emblematica la gioconda
da che cosa deriva l'enigmaticità di
questo volto questo voto sul quale
continuamente ci interroghiamo e ci
affascina ebbene livingston ancora una
volta una scienziata ha esplorato questo
fenomeno e che cosa visto che
l'alternarsi tra l'impiego nostro della
visione centrale per studiare i dettagli
il naso gli occhi la bocca piuttosto che
la gestalt del volto della gioconda il
suo sorriso stanno alla base di questa
enigmaticità che tanto ci affascina
dunque l'intuizione è un aspetto
importante è importante per l'artista
perché lo è perché l'artista vuole
arrivare in qualche modo al cuore e al
nostro cervello ma importante anche per
noi fruitori per dare la nostra
personalissima interpretazione
dell'opera d'arte
ma che cos'è l'intuizione beh è
l'intuizione è il momento a a tutti noi
lo conosciamo molto bene perché con
questo momento di intuizione risolviamo
moltissimi problemi della nostra vita
quotidiana
ma questo momento così impalpabile
perché dura una manciata di secondi
anche se è così risolutivo a un
riscontro a livello cerebrale
ebbene sì guardate qui questi autori
hanno per esempio studiato con un
elettroencefalogramma piuttosto
sofisticato l'attività cerebrale
confrontando due aspetti il ragionamento
sistematico confrontato con il momento a
tutti questi momenti sono importanti per
l'artista nella sua produzione ma sono
importanti per esempio anche per noi
il dettaglio del volto della gioconda
piuttosto che la globalità
ebbene guardate io non mi dilungherò su
questi risultati ma ciò che vediamo e
che in realtà si attivano popolazioni
cerebrali diverse
l'intuizione importante è quella che
avvicina in qualche modo l'artista al
fruitore che in qualche modo cerca di
immedesimarsi in quello che fa l'artista
ma se noi ci spostiamo per esempio dal
prodotto artistico visivo alla poesia
quale è l'emblema della poesia e la
metafora la metafora è una frase che non
dice la verità è una violazione
letterale
però noi le metafore le capiamo
continuamente per cui se per esempio
leggiamo questa frase la rugiada è un
velo
nessuno di noi si sognerebbe di dire ma
per carità non è vero tutti noi ne
capiamo immediatamente il senso ma
perché succede questo perché in realtà
questi due oggetti apparentemente
lontano condividono delle
caratteristiche entrambi coprono ed
entrambi però sono trasparenti
ecco come arriviamo forse al cuore della
poesia ma a livello cerebrale
anni fa abbiamo voluto studiare
l'attivazione dei soggetti che leggevano
delle metafore e che cosa abbiamo visto
che oltre alle mistero sinistro che come
forse tutti voi sapete controlla la
comprensione del linguaggio si
attivavano moltissime aree anche
nell'emisfero di destra e queste aree
controllano per esempio l'immaginazione
mentale la memoria autobiografica
allora a questo punto che cosa possiamo
dire che si l'arte ci coinvolge
moltissimo dal punto di vista cognitivo
e dal punto di vista emotivo ma la
domanda che vorrei farvi oggi è ma
l'arte può curare può essere considerata
una forma di terapia attenzione io oggi
non vorrei parlare di arti terapie
no io vorrei proprio porre questa
domanda un'opera d'arte così come ci può
curare
ovviamente vorrei spiegarvi però perché
faccio questa domanda è perché per me è
importante perché io sono un medico una
neurologa e naturalmente la mia missione
principale è la cura della persona e
vorrei portarvi degli esempi oggi che mi
coinvolgono direttamente in cui stiamo
cercando di studiare questo aspetto
io direi che studiare questo aspetto è
un dovere etico perché i malati
soprattutto quelli cronici spesso devono
fare dei percorsi difficili che li
costringono in ospedale non solo loro ma
anche i loro familiari
e questo che cosa induce inevitabilmente
isolamento sociale isolamento sociale
vuol dire isolamento culturale e
isolamento culturale vuol dire
isolamento artistico però l'arte è un
diritto di tutti per cui etica.mente
lehár chi quotidianamente sono sotto i
nostri occhi ma non sempre sotto gli
occhi dei malati fra queste arti il
cinema il cinema è meraviglioso perché
visita i luoghi più reconditi della
nostra anima ci fa riflettere e in
qualche modo ci emoziona ecco è talmente
è talmente così profondamente importante
che viene definita la settima arte
bene a questo punto io vorrei dirvi una
cosa sarà perché sono napoletana però
secondo me nella vita più di un pizzico
di fortuna e molto importanti un
beneficio
io ho l'onore
di dirigere un centro di neuropsicologia
cognitiva in un grande ospedale
l'ospedale niguarda di milano
ma la fortuna non finisce qua ovviamente
io mi occupo di malati per esempio i
malati con demenza di alzheimer
la seconda fortuna vuole che questo
ospedale ospiti una meravigliosa sala di
proiezione
grazie a medicine ma medicine ma che
cos'è è una fondazione che come missione
principale a quella di costruire di
portare il cinema nei luoghi di cura
ebbene c'è una terza combinazione molto
fortunata niguarda è a due passi dalla
cineteca italiana orgoglio di tutta la
cultura italiana perché la cineteca
italiana e la memoria di tutti noi
contiene seleziona migliaia centinaia di
migliaia di video che rappresentano
anche la nostra storia personale e da
qui nasce il primo tentativo di progetto
cioè il progetto si chiede ma noi
possiamo usare dei video per curare le
persone si può trovare questo effetto ed
in particolare noi che cosa abbiamo
voluto vedere
selezionando sostanzialmente dei video
dalla cineteca italiana in particolare
dei video a contenuto emotivo positivo
dei pezzi di cartone animato delle
bellissime pubblicità di un tempo li
abbiamo confrontati con dei video neutri
e abbiamo studiato le competenze emotive
delle persone prima e dopo l'esposizione
a questi video e guardate questa è
un'immagine scientifica ma si commenta
da sola però vorrei dirvi due parole
sulla sinistra e il dopo aver visto dei
video a contenuti emotivi confrontati
sulla destra su quella minima striscetta
blu che sono invece i video neutri e che
cosa abbiamo visto che
straordinariamente le competenze emotive
la capacità di capire le emozioni ma
migliorano significativamente dopo
l'esposizione
allora una riflessione e una riflessione
clinica
l'emozione è una componente fondamentale
che spesso si dimentica nei processi di
diagnosi e di cura per esempio la
riabilitazione dei malati
allora si comincia a intravedere qualche
cosa che cosa possiamo dire adesso che è
molto importante e fondante la relazione
tra l'artista e noi fruitori
noi tentiamo di immedesimarci no quando
leggiamo qualche cosa
quando leggiamo una raccolta di poesie
vogliamo capire che cosa lo scrittore
vuole esprimere bene questa cosa l'ha
capita molto bene antonello fresu che
non solo è un grandissimo artista visivo
ma è anche uno psichiatra e
psicoterapeuta ed ecco il suo progetto
ri trascrizioni una scrivania
un'opera d'arte un libro bianco una
fonte luminosa e l'invito a tutte le
persone come voi a ricopiare a mano una
parte dell'opera d'arte
e così si consolida la memoria
dell'artista ma si arricchisce l'opera
d'arte anche della nostra personale
memoria e delle nostre emozioni
in questo momento in tutta italia
ritrascrizione sta avvenendo
all'università di pavia all'università
di milano
qua vicino a carpi a fossoli dove stanno
gli copiando se questo è un uomo
ma la cosa più bella a cagliari in un
ambulatorio di territorio che cura gli
ammalati di mente gli ammalati di mente
hanno scelto e stanno finendo di copiare
il buio oltre la siepe allora in qualche
modo l'arte può curare ma la terapia può
diventare arte allora giacomo giannini è
un grande artista e adesso è anche un
paziente e si ritrova ad assumere 5
farmaci al giorno per bocca come tutti
gli artisti tende a raccogliere spesso e
volentieri oggetti che non servono a
nulla
e così ha fatto con i blister cioè le
confezioni che contengono i farmaci ecco
qua ha cominciato a fare questo servono
a qualche cosa direi di sì sono
diventate opere d'arte questi blister
sono delle semplici fotografie sono
maschere emotive più o meno asimmetriche
femminili maschili addirittura il
riciclo della terapia può diventare arte
non solo
giacomo giannini si è curato una volta
quei farmaci due volte producendo l'arte
ma può a sua volta curare per esempio
facendo delle mostre con questi oggetti
bene ma allora alla base di tutto questo
perché l'arte così importante da dove il
legame secondo me l'empatia
che cos'è l'empatia è un comportamento
umano per fortuna irriducibile
nonostante i tempi oscuri e perché è
fantastica l'empatia perché l'empatia
avvicina dei campi culturali diverse fa
incontrare persone molto diverse tra di
loro creando delle unioni e delle
interazioni originali se non addirittura
trascendentali ho parlato a una capra
era sola sul prato era legata salsi ad
erba bagnata dalla pioggia belava quell
uguale belato era fraterno al mio dolore
ed io risposi prima per celia poi perché
il dolore è eterno
ha una voce e non varia questa voce
sentiva genere in una capra solitaria in
una capra dal viso semita sentiva
querelarsi ogni altro male ogni altra
vita per me ci sono dei pesa dei
paesaggi naturali e dei paesaggi
artistici che sono dei veri e propri
luoghi dell'anima
ecco per me questo è un luogo dell'anima
questo è l'ex padiglione psichiatrico
paolo pini di milano e l'attuale museo
di arti psichiatriche di milano in
questo museo opere artistiche di grandi
artisti dell'accademia di brera insieme
a opere invece gli ammalati psichiatrici
sono presenti anonimamente
questo è un luogo dell'anima per me e lo
è perché inizia il mio il luogo del mio
primo tirocini o io volevo fare la
psichiatra sono proprio una banderuola
disegnatrice psichiatra e alla fine
neuroscienziata questo è un luogo di
bellezza di felicità di cura di dolore e
di consolazione
[Applauso]
[Musica]